hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast preserving data integrity
21 CFR part 11 compliance and osmolality
as a process parameter presented by
Angela basa Coase CEO of touchstone
technologies incorporated
also joining Miss Bossy dos are dr.
Kristina right Android and iron of
advanced instruments I'm Christie jewel
of lab rats and I'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by laberd's and sponsored
by advanced instruments advanced
instruments has been the market leader
for osmolality solutions since 1955 they
are focused on serving the
biopharmaceutical industry by delivering
innovative solutions that meet customer
needs across the value chain for more
information on our sponsor please visit
a I companies com
get started I would like to remind
everyone that today's event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate in several ways you can
submit as many questions as you want at
any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation additionally we want to
hear from you and we will be conducting
a few polls throughout the presentation
and we appreciate your participation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or use that ask
a question box to let us know you're
experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
i'd now like to introduce our first
presenter angela Bosco's angela Bosco's
is the CEO of touchstone technologies
incorporated her employers and clients
range from Roche to Stanford Hospital
buzzer goes his co-author of the
original 24 CFR part 11
she holds a patent on virtual validation
has co-authored a book on computerized
systems and clinical research with the
FDA and assists the FDA with new
guidance on data integrity
biography on Miss Bossy dos please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
miss Vaz de cosas you may now begin your
presentation
well Thank You Christy for that
introduction and good morning everyone
all good afternoon depending on your
time zone my name is Angela bicycles and
squares this said I am one of the
original authors of 21 CFR 11 and today
I am going to be speaking on data
integrity and 21 CFR 11 and explain how
those two work together and weigh FDA is
very very keen on them and then I'll
pass the presentation back to Christy
and she will introduce the instruments
folk who will talk about how to achieve
compliance with advanced instruments so
let's start off with what is data
integrity well very very simply the data
that you start with is there data that
you end up with so at the origin and the
destination the data is identical to do
that we have various methods but before
I start on those both of the 21 CFI
eleven methods I need to read to use the
official definition for data integrity
and that is data integrity is defined as
the extent to which all data whether
electronic or paper based a complete
consistent accurate trustworthy and
reliable throughout the data lifecycle
from creation through through archival
stages and their eventual destruction so
regulatory agencies life sciences
industries we need to have the data to
be accurate to ensure that the subject
and patient rights and safety and the
scientific value of clinical studies
valid and can be trusted the other way
to think about data integrity means the
attributable legible contemporaneous
original and accurate alcohol where
of doing data and 21 CFR 11 is the way
that we ensure that alcohol is achieved
with the data so that brings us to 21
CFR 11 I am
a 21 CFR 11 evangelist I feel exactly
like this Herald person here I have
passion for 21 CFR 11 and at this point
I'd like to do a survey of how many of
you absolutely love 21 CFR 11
and we'll wait a couple of seconds to
get the responses
and yeah I love 21 CFR 11 said no one
ever
I will the survey at the end of the
presentation as well to see if it could
change your mind about 21 CFR 11 because
it is my thesis that is very easy to
understand and very useful to use to
enter data integrity so to begin with
I'm going to give you a little bit of a
history of 21 CFR 11 so that will
explain to you what the rule looks like
today and why it looks like the way it
looks so I want to take you back to the
beginnings of time at least in computer
life around at 1983 and in 1983 there
was an FBI investigator who found a
computer in a company he had gone to
investigate unfortunately he had noticed
this was not the first company that was
using computers and in 1983 he wrote a
very thoughtful paper that's still on
the FBI website explaining what
computers where you know they use punch
cards they had dust matrix printers and
explained all the pieces and what they
were doing and he said and this is not
the last paragraph in the paper it's the
you know a couple of paragraphs before
the last paragraph
he said computers are being used in
increasing numbers in the pharma
industry it is possible that in the
future many companies including smaller
ones will be using computers wow that
was 1983 now of course we use computers
for everything and we have GAMP five to
tell us how to validate computers but
starting in 1983 FBA got a little
worried about this computer things and
started adding verbage in the predicate
rules and when I say predicate rules and
mean things like part 58 part 2 11 part
312 part 820 those are predicate rules
and they had verbage that was added to
them to deal with computer systems and
just keep that in mind and I'll cycle
back to it later so here is 21 CFR 11
the rule the three sub parts subpart a
is general provisions B is electronic
records and C is electronic signatures I
will not go over general provisions
since it's the scope and definitions and
but yes it needs to be implemented but
let's look into more detail in
electronic records and electronic
signatures and in order to make it
obvious what we were trying to do at the
time I am going to use three examples
one will be your bank statements online
bank statements the second one will be a
coffee machine and the third one will be
your Bluetooth device so let's start off
before I even go into that which systems
need to be compliant which records need
to be compliant I think of this as
buckets and I have three buckets here
one is assistance at control GXP data
word rgxt data anything as clinical
laboratory or manufacturing data and the
second one is systems that are used to
make quality decisions what I mean by
that is things like documented evidence
of SOPs your tracking list like a
suppliers you
audits and of course any Quality
Assurance data that you might have and
then there's a third bucket and the
third bucket is sort of a little bit of
a catch-all but it basically says if the
computer system contains data that some
house somewhere will find its way into
an electro to a submission to an agency
then it needs to be part 11 compliant of
course the good news is today we
actually have a risk-based approach to
cut back on the amount of work that
needs to be done to ensure that the data
is compliant so electronic records
like I said a subpart B and I am going
to start by defining by orienting you to
21 CFR 11 a little bit so as you
probably aware 21 CFR is volume 21 of
the Code of Federal Regulations which
applies to the Food Drug and Cosmetic
Act of 1906 so it is a book if as it
were the book has chapters and chapters
are things like 11 58 11 the predicate
rules are chapters and so this part 11
and when the chapters have paragraph
subparagraph etc so let's start with 11
10 and by the way if you have two digits
after the 11 dot then it's electronic
records if you have three digits it's
electronic signatures so we'll start
with 11 10 and 11 10 a is validation be
accurate and complete copies of records
see protection of Records the limited
system access the audit trails F
operational system checks G Authority
checks H device checks eye training J
written policies for electron
signatures and cake control over systems
documentation and in the next few slides
I will go over each part in a little
more detail
I will use my FDA to English dictionary
to translate this into English however I
want to point out that 1110 is about
closed systems now you might see the FDA
is here the legalese here that basically
says a closed system is a system that is
inside your firewall that's basically
what that says and after closed systems
we have open systems open systems
conversely a system that are outside
your firewall so if you are inside the
firewall you go with 1110 if you're
outside the firewall
you also need digital signatures for
open systems and what I'll do when I go
through more detail I will explain
digital signatures
11:50 requirements were signed
electronic record 1170 linking records
to signatures and if you're sitting
there thinking but but but you told us
electronic signatures have three digits
yeah guys this is the government okay
bear with me so then we hop over that
electronic signatures proper 11100
general requirements for electronic
signatures 200 electronic signature
components and controls and 300 controls
for identification codes and passwords
so let me unpack these a little bit more
so I am going to start with 21 CFR 1110
a also known as computer systems
validation now this is not anything new
all this covers all the previously added
verbage that FDA put in the predicate
rules to cover computer systems however
I have a mission for you here as there
is more to this and I will read it out
and tell you the true story
so 1110 a says procedures should be in
place for validation of systems to
ensure accuracy reliability consistent
intended performance and the ability to
discern invalid or altered records data
integrity merge and the sir I want to
tell you this is a true story we are
familiar with terms like Six Sigma today
quality by design however back in the
80s when these things started we had a
concept called total quality management
that was instigated by a chap called
Deming
I'm professor damming actually took this
to Japan because it was rejected in the
US and this is the reason that Japan
today has such great reputation for
quality however what happened at the
time after he had implemented this in
Japan an American company ordered 10,000
widgets from a Japanese company 10,000
widgets I cannot remember what the
widgets where and I do not know if you
know this but you if you order in bulk
we usually have an acceptance threshold
so for example if you order 10,000 glass
test tubes you usually say hey we get it
you know the test is in the warehouse I
have to be thrown into the loading
pallets and thrown to the dog thrown
into the truck thrown into the Train
turn onto another truck and then thrown
into receiving dog somehow somewhere
maybe up to six glass test tubes will
break in there so we have an acceptance
threshold that says okay well move six
out of the ten thousands glass test
tubes full P we will accept the shipment
and pay for it mister the American
company orders ten thousand widgets from
the Japanese company and they add the
claws of is six out of ten thousand of
forty we will accept the shipment and
pay for it a few weeks later they get a
big box and a little box and they open
the big box and in there they're nine
thousand nine hundred and ninety four
perfectly good widgets which is a little
puzzling what's the little box so they
open the little box and inside there are
six 2d widgets with a letter that says
we do not understand why you wanted
faulty widgets however here they are
wrapped separately
we hope you enjoyed our service and will
order from us again and what this was
doing is it insured accuracy reliability
consistent intended performance in all
the good widgets and the ability to
discern invalid or altered widgets and
they were wrapped separately so this is
all you have to achieve when you're
doing computer systems validation no
pressure but let's take the rest of 21
CFR 11 and the I will be going through
this quite rapidly but we'll start with
accurate records generation 21 CFR 1110
B this is where if you print your bank
statements from online you're able to
see an accurate representation of what
the bank computer has gone line 11 10 C
protection of records you protect your
records if the IRS wants to see your
record three years later you can still
retrieve them whether you are archiving
them you're backing them up and of
course you know how to do it this is
protection of Records 11 10 D limited
system access procedures to make sure
that your neighbor or your teenage
offspring does not get into your bank
accounts so you limit the access to only
yourself and your spouse 11 10 e and all
the trails people get very worried about
audit trails because they say that you
want a secure computer-generated
time-stamped audit trails that do not
obscure previously recorded information
this is just like a bank statement if
you think about it your bank statement
has secured computer-generated timestamp
records so if you deposit $100 at 10
a.m.
and then you withdraw $80 a ten-ton you
have both transactions described in your
bank statement and the 80 withdrawal
does not obscure the 100 deposit F G and
H are procedural so 1110 F is
operational system checks also known as
work flow and what this says if you want
to make coffee with a coffee machine
you want to add water and coffee and
then press the brew button if you add
water but no coffee you'll get hot water
graceful tea but not coffee if you add
coffee but no water and then press the
brew button you will get smoke coming
out of the machine so 11 can ask as if
there are steps that need to be taking
place and the sequence they need to take
place needs to be enforced through the
system this is called workflow what
authority checks 11 10 G if you go to
your bank and write a check to cash for
$100 the cashier will check your ID and
then will simply give you the cash
however if you were to go to the same
Bank same cashier way to check for
$10,000 see what happens
well the cashier will check your ID but
then call over a person that has the
authority to release ten thousand
dollars in your company this is
implemented by having the manager
approved something and say the data
entry person can enter data but cannot
approve data and then device checks this
is like your Bluetooth instead of your
Bluetooth picking up everybody's
conversation you can only pick up
conversation from your phone so this is
linking this is the handshake between
you are between two devices usually used
for instruments now if you're wondering
how the heck we wrote 9:20 first version
of 21 CFR 11 in 1992 and if you are
wondering how the heck we knew about
bluetooth devices in 92 what we didn't
we actually use garage door openers as
our example the next one is the 11 10 I
training this is not specific to 21 CFR
11 it applies to everything's I will not
go through this 11 10 J this is
something again
it's 2 digits but electronic signatures
and it basically says that all employees
if you are going to be using electronic
signatures in your company your
employees have to sign a statement that
I understand that electronic signatures
are legally binding and have the same
meaning as handwritten signatures so I
always recommend abusing pizza and beer
for this activity have a big party and
oh of course you can use comfort food
and comfort beverage of your choice they
have a big party get everybody in and
then get them to sign and make sure you
check their ID and also make sure that
the name they're signing is the not the
anglicized one but the actual name on
their ID documentation of course is the
same as everything else and then we come
out of closed systems and pop over to
1130 which is digital signatures for
open systems so now we're outside the
firewall and you have seen digital
signatures when you first log into your
bank account you will get a message that
says hey
I do not know this computer who are you
we will send you a code so you take the
code you put that in your computer and
then the bank computer can use your
computer's IP address as your code but
you can use VPN or you can use one of
those cards that generate a new number
every seven seconds those are all forms
of digital signatures electronic
signature manifestations is the rule
I'll show you the next slide basically
they should look like
Angela bicycles 0 5 September 2008 and
the timestamp and the reason for the
signatures so the difference between
digital signatures and electronic
signatures is digital signatures are
just a code in VPN it would be an extra
password the electronic signature
actually has to tell you who it is when
it happened and you wanted in universal
date format and why you are applying
this signature linking records to
signatures this is saying that if you
have a signature in the system you
cannot do like you can do today you can
today you can go on the internet and
copy Barack Obama's signature or Donald
Trump's signature and put in those as
many checks as you want
what linking records the signature says
is do not allow people to
Excise and paste an electronic signature
and speaking about electronic signatures
this is what an electronic signature
looks like for us you can see Lisa Jones
digitally signed blah blah blah
well if you go to somewhere like a
supermarket or another shop you would be
signing with the stylus they're the same
thing
so electronic signatures that will be
unique but you have to ensure that you
send something to FDA to let them know
that you will be using electronic
signatures and then remember that the
natural log that came out of the piece
and beer party well that needs to be
kept in case the FDA inspects you
because they will want to see that
signature log however I have the address
on this slide if you descend the
certification like I said keep hold of
the signature log components and
controls of electronic signatures you
have to have at least two parts and we
know it's usually user name and password
and then controls for identification
codes and passwords I would say all of
this needs to be in your security SOP
and it's very straightforward think of a
credit card if you are a debit card if
you would lose your credit card or debit
card you would get a replacement you
would cancel the other one you would let
people know etc etc so I have some
references here for you if you want to
read more about these and I included
annex 11 which is the European version
and what I'm going to do now is I'm
going to take some slides from one of my
FBI contacts and explain the marriage
between 21 CFR 11 and data integrity so
I want to thank all these people
or putting these slides together and
fda's does by saying that you know
garbage in garbage out you want to make
sure you have clean data so remember I
said earlier in the presentation that
what FDA did is initially it added the
verbage for a computer control inside
the predicate rules so I'm just going to
show you one of these slides and I have
a few other slides that you can use for
reference but it's not a new concept
it's been around since the 80s as I
mentioned earlier but notice for example
here
2:11 part 68 a saved the yeah to 11 plus
68 requires a backup data exact and
complete and secure from alteration
inadvertent alesia's or loss hey does
that sound familiar
it's 1110 C that says records must be
protected to enable the accurate and
ready retrieval throughout the records
retention period or another example we
have i CH q7 says a GMP related
computerized system should be validated
we know the ones that the GMP related
with those three buckets and we have
1110 a procedure should be in place for
validation of systems to ensure accuracy
reliability consistent intended
performance and the ability to discern
invalid or altered records another one
we have that says implement
documentation controls to attribute
access to specific individual which says
to not share your login credentials
21 CFR 11:10 D procedure should be in
place to limit system access to
authorized users the next one same and
by the way at the bottom of these s FDA
slides there is the warning letter that
you can look to to get more detail and
then we have this one that says when
does electronic data become cGMP record
and basically the minute you generate
data to satisfy a cgmp requirement all
data becomes a cGMP record and remember
the alcohol earlier slide that we said
it needs to be original so it is not
acceptable to record data on pieces of
paper that will be discarded after the
data are transcribed while you do not
see this in 21 CFR 11 specifically you
would find it in annex 11 and in 21 CFR
11 it is with data integrity and good
documentation practices audit trails FDA
recommends audit trails capture changes
there and they're reviewed because 11 10
e are the trails if you look at the
bottom part of audit trail it says that
audit trails are electronic records too
so with that I have reached the end of
my presentation I'd like to pass you
back to Christi who will also run a poll
on how much more you love 21 CFI 11 now
that you see how simple and scalable it
is
Christie back to you
thank you ms vizago's that was an
excellent presentation and a lot of
information to take in so to our
audience I would like to take your pulse
now that you are a little bit more
informed so here comes our second poll
okay kicking off the second part of our
presentation we have dr. Kristina right
in issue a denial
dr. Christina Wright is an application
scientists at advanced instruments and
holds a PhD in biomedical science with a
background in academia and
biopharmaceutical developments dr.
Wright has a deep understanding of the
value of osmolality testing throughout
bio processing miss Shiu denier is a
senior production manager at advanced
instruments focused on the biotech
industry she has a background in
research and product management driving
successful innovative solutions to
answer customer needs in the life
science market dr. Ryder MS Nayar the
floor is yours
thank you so much Christy and thank you
again Angela for your wonderful
presentation as Christy mentioned we
will now speak a little bit more about
advanced instrument about our technology
and some of what we have to offer even
beyond the instruments themselves so we
are dedicated to providing valuable
tools that help with bio processing
control so just to get into the value of
osmolality testing a little bit before
we actually get into the instrumentation
the definition of osmolality is really a
concentration of any aqueous solution is
typically expressed as milliosmoles per
kilogram of water and you'll notice that
the advanced instruments oz mama mama
ters take advantage of freezing point
depression there are other properties of
solutions that can be measured and
converted into osmolality such as vapor
pressure or osmotic pressure if you're
looking at a membrane osmometry however
freezing point depression remains the
most accurate and precise method for
measuring osmolality and that is the
technique that we use here at advanced
instruments with all of our house
monitors
so the question is where is osmolality
tested
so you'll see here a few examples just
within upstream processing for a
monoclonal antibodies and I say that
because obviously this also extends into
other areas of biopharmaceuticals but we
wanted to focus in on this one process
in particular so if you're looking at
upstream processing osmolality testing
can really be valuable from the very
beginning from cell line development and
establishing which clones which cell
lines which growth factors and what
environment is suitable for your needs
to really make sure that your process is
under control from the very start so
cell line development contributing to
optimal cell density as well as tighter
with media preparation osmolality
testing is a great way to make sure that
the media whether it's outsourced or
made in-house is of the right
composition and that's again to just
ensure that you have optimal cell growth
throughout your culturing process and
for the monitoring itself why not use
osmolality as an improv controlled
during your monitoring process this is a
great way to just check on the health of
the cell and also make sure that you're
promoting maximum cell density and yield
as we look further into the purification
process or filtration steps for
monoclonal antibodies we can start again
with buffer preparation and you know I
like to think of this as being similar
to the media preparation just using
osmolality as a control as a check a
sanity check if you will to make sure
that your buffers have been mixed
properly that the overall concentration
of your solution is right where it's
supposed to be and that's really a great
way to start off the process and make
sure that you can optimize again the
quality and yield of your eventual
product then as we look at your unit
operations for chromatography and for
your filtration steps for buffer
exchange and concentration we really are
focusing again on the highest quality
the highest yield of your products so
for chromatography it's very possible to
use auto allottee testing in process as
far as being used as a predictor really
for protein concentration we have a
really great study that we've just
completed and we'd be happy to share
information to show that osmolality is a
really great indicator for protein
concentration throughout chromatography
steps as far as buffer exchange it can
be used similarly in process as you're
looking at the number of diaval Yume's
that you're using for your exchanges or
your filtration processes it's really a
great idea to use osmolality to make
sure that your exchanges are complete
you could potentially optimize the
number of exchanges that you're using
and make sure that you have thorough
exchange throughout the process
and last but not least when we're
looking at monoclonal antibody
formulation and final product we have
formulation development which similarly
to the cell line development process you
have a lot of different situations
experimental conditions that you want to
test at a time this is a great time to
use a more high throughput tool and
Shwetha will be discussing some of
options as far as our instruments a
little bit later in our presentation but
just to introduce the idea of multi
sample testing this would be a great
application for that final formulation
monitoring and verifying the
concentration of your excipient and
osmolality testing can also be used to
look at the soluble content of any
formulation and we know that the
osmolality contributes to any potential
injection site pain
so again just measuring osmolality here
is a really great check at final
formulation and then when we talk about
release
specifications osmolality is fairly
standard in this area but it's always
good to point out that this is another
area where osmolality testing brings
value and additionally they could serve
as another check for product stability
so at this point I will hand over our
presentation to Shui denier and she will
discuss some of our technology and a lot
of the other services that we have to
offer
christena now as you've all seen
osmolality is a very valuable process
parameter across the workflow and we
here at advanced instruments are really
dedicated to providing products such as
an automaton and associated services to
optimize your bio processing works well
for over 60 years
reed advanced instruments have built an
in-depth understanding of freezing point
depression technology and provided
solutions for all molality testing
across clinical and biotech industry but
over the last two years we've really
focused on developing our products to
specifically meet the changing needs of
the bio farmer market part of meeting
the needs is understanding the many
facets of bio manufacturing such as QC
final product so finish
now in addition to making the products
cater to our customers we also provide
trusted high level of service and
support we've developed a thorough
portfolio of support options for our
customers from installation and training
to iqq validation packages we also offer
service packages that include preventive
maintenance and 24/7 support
therefore advanced instruments with the
product and services truly have you
covered for your molality testing needs
but we are here truly to find out how
our instrument can meet and support the
21 CFR part 11 needs that Angela
highlighted our low tech portfolio
offers a robust range of all monitors
for low and high throughput workflows
our automotive tech is a single sample
of lammeter developed specifically for
our biotech customers with low testing
needs and it's multisample counterpart
is the osmotic probe that was launched
recently these instruments provide the
obvious osmolality testing with high
accuracy and precision intuitive design
but it also incorporates many features
that are important to our biotech
customers such as audit trail electronic
data management electronic signatures
features that ensure that these
instruments can support the 21 CFR part
11 compliant now I'll focus on the
different aspects of the 21 CFR part 11
compliant and how our Auto Tech
portfolio meets those needs
first is complete accurate record all
data generated by our Osmo tech and
osmotic probe can be stored
electronically either on the device with
unlimited storage directly onto the
network automatically on a USB key or
even integrated into the lab systems as
required the data generated cannot be
altered we do have the ability however
to add comments to the results and adds
reasons for any changes being made to
give you the flow traceability now
electronic data generated can be of two
formats giving you flexibility a PDF or
a CSV format and above all these
instruments can be validated or
qualified using our comprehensive iqq
package to always ensure that the system
is performing according to manufacturer
requirements next is audit trail our
Alma tech Osmo tech Pro micros monitors
record any and all changes as part of
audit trail this includes creation of
users changes in settings etc the
records are all time-stamped identified
by the user who made the changes these
records cannot be modified or deleted
additionally it can be configured though
to require a reason for the changes so
you have that traceability this gives
you a true and complete audit trail that
you're looking for access control now I
mentioned users earlier and I want to go
a little bit more in depth talking about
the different types of user access your
the ability to have three levels of user
access administrator supervisor and
operator all of these accounts are
password protected and the passwords can
be configured to require a minimum
number of characters there's also a lot
of flexibility here to customize and
configure the password for instance you
can use capitals lowercase numbers you
can even have a pre expire password or
have a password expire after a certain
period of time forcing the user to
change their password these three levels
of users also have the ability to
customize what functions each of them
can do you can log in and require that
an operator cannot calibrate the
instruments but a supervisor can do so
and that can be customized on the
instrument last but not the least I want
to talk about electronic signature to
truly get a strong signature you also
have the ability to connect the device
to an Active Directory server this
really gives you the ability to easily
manage
different users in your lab and the
different access levels your IT team can
quickly allocate a certain number of
users to be an administrator a
supervisor or an operator and integrate
that with our instrument therefore you
can see now that with complete accurate
record as a child data management user
user access levels and electronic record
an awesome attack and ultimate X Pro
macros monitor it's really supporting
and meeting the 21 CFR part 11 compliant
and helping you preserve that data
integrity in your biopharmaceutical
workflow now I'd like to thank you all
for listening and hand it over back to
Christi for our live Q&A session
Thank You dr. Wright in desire for your
presentation and welcome back Miss Bossy
gose we will now start the live Q&A
portion of our webinar if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now just click on that ask a question
box located the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many questions as
we have time for we have some great
questions coming in let's start with why
is asthma Holliday needed if I am
testing pH and conductivity great thank
you for the question so I just I'll try
to answer this as briefly as possible so
kind of referring to the downstream
process and when we were discussing the
value of osmolality testing really it's
not to replace pH and conductivity
obviously those are pre key parameters
for this area however we have a number
of studies that have shown that
osmolality actually provides additional
value it can serve as an orthogonal or
complementary parameter if you will to
pH and conductivity and is a really good
way to check buffer concentrations if
you are in the preparation area that we
discussed and it can also serve as a
predictor of sorts for protein
concentration in more of an inline or in
process rather parameter for
chromatography
thank you on to our next question Gambas
buzzer possibly this one's for you what
is the difference between 21 CFR 11 and
M X 11
thank you yeah age is the the difference
between part 11 and annex 11 so annex 11
is a much newer regulation that has
Louis European regulation but it has
huge huge overlap with 21 CFR 11 also
annex 11 has a little bit of a slant
towards manufacturing but both party
Levin and onyx 11 have the covered the
entire GXP area also I believe that you
can send questions after we finish here
and if you like I can send your report
on similarities and differences but
short answer is there about 85% the same
just different Burbage and different age
Thank You Vince bicycles now I have a
question coming in I'm in formulation
and I'm not concerned with 21 CFR part
11 compliance do you have any up any
other options
so great question really all of our
options are based into one instrument or
the other so we discussed the Osmo Tec
single sample AHS vomiter and the Osmo
tech pro for multi sample more high
throughput needs the great thing about
them is that they are pretty flexible
and sweet to spoke to this a little bit
but just to highlight the fact that even
if you don't currently feel like you
need to meet the regulations that were
discussed in this presentation it's
something that could potentially change
over time and the systems are really
great tools that can kind of follow you
as you grow so if there are pieces that
are interesting to you or you feel like
you just want to incorporate them into
your procedures and your methods you can
enable those features on the device if
you're not interested in certain
features certainly you can disable as
many of those as you'd like but we want
to give you the opportunity to really
have all of these features at your
fingertip and that's what we offer with
both instruments
Thank You Joseph right now while I'm
discussing compliance does it as vomiter
comply with 21 CFR part 11
thank you for that question the avila
tech and the Osmo Tech Pro micros
monitors support 21 CFR part 11
requirements and regulation
okay our next question do you need a
computer to be connected to the Oz mama
to access the data
and it's a very interesting question you
actually don't need a computer to be
connected to the device to be accessing
the data you can connect so you can
access the data by simply touching the
touchscreen display as the data is all
stored within the device additionally
you have the ability to send that data
to a folder within your network in the
form of a PDF or a CSV and you can
access it that way we've also built in
an embedded web server on the device
what that means is if you are in another
building you can remotely access the
data that's on this device by simply
typing in the IP address in your web
browser so you have different flexible
ways of accessing the data and without
having any computer directly connected
to it or solely dedicated to it
Thank You Vizier now miss positives
let's come over to you so is computer
systems validation the same as 21 CFR 11
all right so this is a little confusing
computer systems validation it's
basically all the verbage that was in
the predicate rules has now been moved
over to computer system validation so as
part of part 11 you have computer
systems validation but the way to
implement part 11 is to make it part of
computer systems validation so it's sort
of their one inside the other however
they're not the same thing that they
break down to two different guidance
documents and of course there's gram
five which is computer systems
validation and not the rest of part 11
and it's a confusing I know I hope my
answer made sense
thank you Miss vizago's now we have some
great questions coming in we're almost
out of time so I do want to remind our
audience that those questions we do not
have time to answer today and those that
come in during the on-demand period they
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration so this box
goes one more for you here I have not
seen citations for 21 CFR 11 do
regulatory authorities still inspect for
21 CFR 11 yes they do but they're sneaky
about it the citation is actually
written against the predicate rule or
against data integrity so I recently saw
it data integrity citation by an
Austrian regulatory authority but
remember how I said the verbage is
inside 311 458 you will actually see the
citation against the predicate rule so
yes they are part 11 citations but
unless you know how to look for them you
would not be able to detect them at the
one point I do want to make is anything
FBA has stepped up part 11 inspections
since they did the add-on inspections in
2012 and they found it a very productive
field shall we say so they hide a lot
more people to be doing Korolev
inspections the training inspectors so
they're really stepping tapper so it's
an extremely important part of
inspections now
thank you Miss buzzer goes now before we
go I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions we did have quite
a few questions what we were unable to
answer today so I do want to reiterate
that those questions we didn't answer
and those questions that do come in
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration I would once again
like to thank ms Angela Baz ago dr.
Kristina right amos Wedemeyer for their
time today and for their important
contributions and data integrity we
would also like to thank laberd's ubb
our sponsor advanced instruments for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand
fabrics will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
at the close of this presentation a
survey will pop up on your screen and
your participation is greatly
appreciated your answers help us improve
our webinar program thank you for
joining us and we hope to see you again
soon
you